I'm getting ready for truth birthday I
have a duster that goes but I mean is
this perfect or from matching mommy and
me looks too over-the-top decor and a
seemingly awkward family reunion Khloe
Kardashian through her daughter true
Thompson the dreamiest first birthday
bash ever it's so like that's what it
must have been crazy but it's like I
probably talked so much crap about all
the other first babies like that we're
doing that and you do it the reality
star didn't disappointed celebrating her
baby girl's big day Khloe shared videos
on social media of a cotton candy
machine a sparkly PlayStation an ice
cream popsicle cart and even a petting
zoo filled with colorful ponies I love
it throughs dad Tristan Thompson was
also there despite his and Khloe's
decision to break things off in February
some fans interpreted this moment where
he tries to hold true as a bit awkward
Chloe sister Kim was also there with her
kids she shared this video of her
fashionable five-year-old daughter North
okay guys no I think those shoes off but
the sweetest part of all the family's
decision to give throughs gifts to kids
in need so we did not want presents from
is true we asked that everybody bring a
gift for the Children's Hospital of LA
my favorite part about being a mom I
mean it's so corny but it's just like no
matter how tired you are whatever you
just it's complete bliss when you see
your baby and how happy and like you
just get through it and I was like okay
if I could do anything
[Music]